manifesting this is the practice of
trying to get good results by doing
absolutely nothing at all instead of
telling the universe this is what I want
I tell the universe to show me how
effortlessly this comes to me never
again say I want this because that whole
phrase implies lack I teach you how to
manifest in 30 days here watching that
video I'm reminded of being in third
grade or maybe it's fourth grade at the
beginning of the school year when the
teacher told us to write down our hopes
and dreams for the year on a piece of
paper and she gave us envelopes and told
us to decorate the envelopes with pretty
colors and then we put the paper with
our hopes and dreams into the envelope
and we put our envelopes in a special
box which I think she called our dream
box or open or something like that even
at eight years old I can remember
thinking how pointless and fruitless the
whole exercise was